an unprecedented weight of smoke hanging
over the Manhattan skyline it is the
consequence of wildfires many hundreds
of miles to the North in Canada
across the city as the hours passed the
spectacle persisted a remarkable
reflection of how weather events impact
well beyond where they hit
on the ground New Yorkers were out but
told not to be the health risks of air
like this are not familiar to people
here but they are of a level regularly
experienced in Indian and Chinese cities
it began on Tuesday this was
mid-afternoon it looked more like dusk
and it is persisting from over the
bridge in New Jersey Manhattan obscured
and look at this the Yankees game with
the smoke above yesterday New Yorkers
sore and smelled something that has
never impacted us on this scale before
even as I was out walking the streets
clearly you knew something was happening
that was beyond normal this is an
unprecedented event in our city and New
Yorkers must take precaution
the advice was predictable not to
exercise outside and to wear a mask the
scientists spelled out why
levels that people if they were to be
outside especially if they're exercising
breathing faster they're going to be
inhaling particulates at concentrations
at normal smokers would inhale
this remarkable satellite image on a
loop over Quebec in Canada shows the
cause clusters of wildfires 500 miles
north of New York
more than 100 fires are said to be out
of control it's worse than normal
because of persistently hot dry weather
an area about the size of Belgium has
already been burnt
at its peak the air quality up in New
York was the worst in the world it has
come down now but the winds have brought
the smoke South and here in Washington
the air is said to be unhealthy and has
been all day
no significant weather changes are
expected anytime soon and we are only at
the start of America's Wildfire season
Mark Stone Sky News in Washington